all right in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast we
got a very special guest today I
actually been trying to get you on for a
minute I just haven't hit you up okay
this because I always see you're busy
with first of all you like building cars
and shade you got fight academy but we
got savant young here former pro fighter
also owner and coach at fight academy
Pasadena which is the first spot that I
trained at two years ago yes sir
you know what's really funny though like
when I first started training at a fight
academy
you're just so casual I had no idea you
own the place yeah you know what that's
just my design I'd like to just float
through yeah
be cool humble with everybody and then
I'm happy but hey who's the owner here
I'm looking at him like you're always
just kind of casual and chilling back in
the Nick was like oh he actually owns
the spot I'm like oh man quiet yeah but
you know what you don't want to be that
dude right you're not trying to be that
like douche bag dude that's like hey man
you know you know I'm the guy right oh
yeah I'm the guy yeah I'm good
so for you when you were when you were a
pro fighter I'm always curious about
this it's like how do you transition
from you know finding your whole life
and then not fighting like that that has
always been such a weird thing for me
because I see a lot of fighters who who
I kind of grew up with that wanted to be
a pro fight obviously they didn't make
it that well because you don't know who
the [ __ ] they are right but they've
always had this goal of being this
prizefighter and then afterwards they
didn't think about an after and so they
kind of go down like this spiral and I
don't like how did you how did you kind
of transition out of fighting into doing
what you're doing now initially I mean I
wanted to have a gym I always wanted to
have a gym as a kid when I did karate
before I was even into fighting I had
this dream of owning a gym and we almost
bought a gym me and a wife you know way
back this was in I forgot what just had
to be early 2000s and I wasn't even
ready or some little [ __ ] place in
Highland Park that I probably wish I
would have gotten out cuz now that
shit's booming right now you know I
should have got in there but
it was always something I wanted to do
and typically most I mean I wasn't
trying to be a [ __ ] bouncer you know
I'm like I can't be a bouncer so I
better figure out another way to feed
the sport so my whole thing was I want
to be involved in this sport for a long
time to come
you know like once I'm done fighting I
want to kind of you know groom other
fighters to you know cut not following
my life but at least follow into some
like authenticity you know follow what
somebody that's really been there really
done it no gimmicks and now they you
know they called me all Gmail and I kind
of took that role and you go from being
in the spotlight to carrying the bucket
you know I still get the same feel I
feel like I win when the guys win and I
feel like I lose when they lose so being
that I know the game and I know what
they're going through I'm just
appreciative to be part of that whole
experience to be honest you know we were
just talking about this you know off off
the podcast but that authenticity factor
I feel like because Sports eventually I
mean not even eventually it is a [ __ ]
business right huge bill and I think
when I first started training you know I
was just looking up a bunch of trainers
out in the whole area and actually
before I even signed up with Nick I even
know what Nick look like right first
thing I wanted to know was does this
person have professional fights under
the belt that's it
a lot of people don't write and they
want to train people which is the oddest
thing that I always see and I don't
understand why that is like I don't find
it you're kind of like a crook well it
feels like it feels like it is some
snake oil you know because like Nick for
instance you know Nick he has experience
like he has been in a ring and fought
people so I respect the fact that you're
teaching from a point of experience you
know to me like I could tell you I'm a
surgeon it [ __ ] cut that for you work on
this Apple person they see what you do
with this there's just a lot of that
going on and people are taking advantage
of it because there's a lot of new
people to the sport like new people that
are getting into it they look on TV they
go Google whatever
and then they figured like oh this guy
looks like he know what he's doing
because he you know says he does or post
some pictures in the ring with somebody
but you don't ever see actual fight
footage or any type of like write-up so
you gotta find something and Google's
powerful man you can find the fake quick
that's that's the weird thing so there
was a there was a guy that I wanted to
train with first before I wanted to go
into kickboxing I just wanted to do
strict boxing at first because when you
first taught me I was like 270 pounds
yeah see you too man I gotta get your
prize hey babies crying I thought you
know quit already
[Laughter]
I respect your game yeah yeah when I
when I first started I did feel like
quitting it was it was hard yeah I think
it was it was difficult because because
I did take one no when I was younger
right and then I just haven't thrown a
kick since since ever and even though I
was a big dude I could still throw a
heel kick so I was like oh maybe I'll be
able to do this stuff but then it was
you know point sparring versus actual
sparring or two different things
they'd only they don't feel the same and
I all day right cuz it's repetitive
there's no like stop and call for points
right it's like that's what we use and
it just keeps going and then you're like
okay so that was actually one of my
biggest problems when we first started
Nick was say like it's like cool you hit
me why'd you stop right it's because I'm
so used to points boy yeah it's like
once you tag somebody it's like I time
out let's get some tea real quick and
you know there's some there's some
there's some good to that cuz I started
out doing a shotokan karate so I used to
do all these like aunt Parker's mmm
tournaments kimple tournaments and the
good thing about the point fighting is
it taught you how to uh it taught you
how to go for clean shots mmm you know I
mean I taught you how to set up things
you know it had to be clean you know it
couldn't be no you know just throwing
whatever but yeah it had to be solid so
it kind of taught me that that was the
one good thing I took from it until I
ran into somebody that actually was a
kickboxer and I tried that and just got
touched up and I was just like you know
it was weird and [ __ ] so then I knew
like man I got to learn how to actually
do continuous fighting yes that of the
point fighting and then I just started
searching and search
for that man you know and I knew that
was like the full form fighting was like
till one of us says we don't want no
more what was the what was the point
where you decided that you wanted to be
a like a professional fighter because I
think a lot of people feel like they can
until they you know get on a mat [ __ ] -
look yeah I mean for me I had a dream of
it I mean I watched like most of the
guys my age we all watched the early
UFC's I was a big fan of Pancrase in
Japan oh yeah yeah and shoot oh we used
to go rent VHS tapes of shoot oh and
pancreas and watch all these videos
thinking like man this is this is dope
when I was in high school and we
literally would get videos get books we
would go out in the backyard and try to
practice what we saw we were literally
trying to learn from from books you know
they have pictures of sequences and [ __ ]
we would try to try they had like those
ancient Chinese scroll no we said there
was a time my wife could she could
confirm this there was a time that Isis
just legit where the kung-fu gate
outside of [ __ ] oh my god that was my
thing like that's way back you remember
that's it yeah with the little slippers
and everything so that's [ __ ] Jim
Kelly style real bad but not man this
this game is I love it man this is this
is a part of me
the fighting came up I just didn't want
to work no more man I went to camp the
day that I made the transition was I was
in camp in big beer with a Quinton
Rampage Jackson Josh Barnett Tito our
team dude I wasn't kept with these dudes
for a few weeks and they were making
good money right I would just live in
this life with them I was a you know we
had a shift there we had coaches getting
up in the morning making us go run come
home food was made here's all your
supplements here's this and I had took a
leave of absence from my actual job that
I was doing at post production at the
time and
went to this camp so I went to this camp
with these guys and literally maybe a
couple weeks into to being there I
called my job and told him you know what
I'm not coming back well I saw how they
were living and it was a believe I might
have been my 30th birthday I think was
my 30th birthday rampage his birthday
was a day I think a day after mine I
celebrated my birthday and camped with
them and I literally just quit my job I
didn't have no fight she thought I was
crazy they helped my wife was like
what's wrong with you
and she stuck around we still here so
yeah man I quit my job and at that point
you know I saw rampage getting ready to
make you know he might have made 400 K
for that fight when he fought against
Matt Lindland here and how much used to
me that's crazy yeah he made some decent
coin back brand page made decent money
back then I ain't gonna lie and I saw
that happen and I saw the work that was
being put in and I was doing the same
work I'm like man I'm running the same
Hills I'm doing the same sparring
arounds I'm doing this with you guys so
I wanted to just take a shot at it
myself man and literally I'm it was
probably a best decision for me because
I know if I didn't do that
then I probably wouldn't be doing this
[ __ ] right now
so who kind of mentored you at that
point then because I feel like it's kind
of hard to jump into something without
somebody really guiding you and kind of
helping you out and in that kind of
sense I had a few different a few
different mentors you know coming up I
had a the person they introduced me to
the sport actually was a guy named Joe
Charles and Joe Charles fought in UFC
like one through four okay this this guy
kind of took me under his wing you know
and brought me up and then I went and
trained I used to train with all the
Armenians out in Hollywood undergo
course efficient so I trained with a lot
of good guys the last coach though who I
was in Big Bear with is uh you know my
current coach now I called him a brother
of mine a coach remind his name is
Antonio McKee whose son is AJ McKee
oh yeah that's my brother you know and
my page a is like a nephew to me so we
became really tight he was the guy that
always thought like you know an in shape
savant that comes ready to go can beat
anybody in the game so he would always
feed me that and tell me what I need to
do and you know you try to drag me to
church and [ __ ] he was that guy you know
so he I knew he had my best interest in
mind so if I had to like single it out
to one person that gave me that drive it
would definitely be Mickey you know it's
interesting cuz I always wonder too you
know maybe you can give some perspective
on this is like yeah I feel like
sometimes like MMA reminds me of
basketball in the sense of there's a lot
of players that I follow in basketball
and there's a lot of people that I that
I follow in MMA and I feel like a lot of
Fighters kind of have all the pieces to
be very successful but it's just like a
game of like engines right it's because
it's hard to say when I look at somebody
who's in the USC and then somebody says
that guy's trash but it's like like for
example let me look like there's a
fighter that I really really [ __ ]
like okay and you know I might like oh
it's Kevin Lee okay
I [ __ ] Kevin I think Kevin Lee can
have a belt yeah there's a lot of people
who disagree with that so good this is a
good one to put it into that perspective
actually occasionally cuz they see him
they see him lose a couple of times
right but every time I seen him lost he
had like championship material it's just
you know during the time when he was
losing he didn't have a coach I didn't
have a focus right and he was a little
too much in his head I think the the in
your head part for most of us fighters
you know we got issues man
most guys that are fighters we a lot of
them got father issues or some sort of
like no male figure so the fighting
becomes your thing right and you be you
you're like revered by people so you
kind of you want to do it and you don't
you know what I mean you get into this
like I love this but [ __ ] I got a fight
but I'm making money doing this yeah my
people love me I got all this this Fame
and whatnot but it's a really uh it's a
tough lonely game you know if you don't
have you know a support group and
luckily like for me I had a decent
support group you know with the wife and
family and my in-laws
people around me that that helped me out
so it kept me going and I had already
committed to it so I had to go full
throttle because I'm not wasn't gonna
make no money no other way but I think
for some of the guys that don't make it
you know it's it's a whose uh to judge
that right like they get like Kevin Lee
Francis you know yeah he's championship
material
he's fighting at a very high level his
last fight was [ __ ] I thought he
killed a dude I thought I thought I was
when that head kick was his name right
and his it was funny cuz when we were
watching because we all know you know he
could he could wrestle yeah so here that
really low stance so I didn't expect him
to throw that high kick man it threw me
off man it was so unfair and that kid
that he was in there wit was a pretty
good wrestler - I think it was
undefeated yes and he's a good wrestler
high level wrestler and I think that was
a reason why he went that route because
you got a guy in there that both can
wrestle they're expecting that and this
is MMA man so that's this is the beauty
of MMA you don't know how it's gonna
work
you know you don't know what's gonna
come about but all you know is you got
two people in there and somebody's
losing he had kicked the living [ __ ] I
saw his spirit come out the back of it
and he was leaned up against the cage
with his hands down his god he slumped
them this podcast is brought to you by
skill share what is Skillshare you ask
it is an online learning community that
offers membership with meaning
Skillshare offers classes designed for
real life so you can learn the things
you want at your pace based on your busy
routine I love it I know a lot of people
out there want to make film for fun or
maybe even as a side hustle there's a
lot of classes that you could take that
Skillshare offers that I know a lot of
people would enjoy there's even a course
called video on a budget because a lot
of people are broke and they just want
to make film and even of course for
iPhone filmmaking because everybody has
a phone I enjoy these classes very much
explore your creativity and get to three
months of premium membership at
Skillshare comm /a brain that's two
whole months
of unlimited access that thousands of
classes for free get started and joined
today by heading to Skillshare comm
slash brain that's two three months of
unlimited access to thousands of classes
at Skillshare dot-com slash brain
because there's people like Kevin Lee
and I'm trying to see about somebody
else who I really I'm kind of sad that
he's gonna retire will retire from them
and mate was clear round tree yeah
because after he fought Eric Anders and
I saw what Tiger Muay Thai did for him
uh and he was just eating up his legs
with those legs
I thought yo he's transformed a lot and
then he's just like I'm done after this
last fight it's tough man I mean and
hopefully he got something else to fall
back on I'm thinking now nowadays it
seemed like the fighters are a little
bit more into like diversifying what
they do you know a lot of these kids are
college educated now it wasn't like that
before you know guys you're just not
just [ __ ] fight yeah you know now
these dudes understand that it's a
business they understand that they have
a a draw or they can create this this
image online or whatnot to where they
can market other things like when I was
coming up it was none of that dude like
you had like somebody else you had to
build your name and you had to fight
credible opponents that was the only way
that you could really build yourself up
was taking tough fights yeah and that
was kind of the route I went like I
didn't have like the absolute most
spectacular record but I was respected
because if you looked at the opposition
that I faced most of those guys people
in my era they didn't want to fight
those dudes well I was kind of shocked
you actually fought at 155 yes yes you
out of your mind
I fought 143 pounds awful I wasn't
ranked number nine in the world at 145
when you when you I didn't know too that
the the Mike diamond knockout that you
had was your last fight that was it that
was your last you want to talk about
killing somebody yeah I thought you
killed him yeah you know that was wanted
to but that was that was my first
Bellator fight I've ever seen oh you
were there I remember oh not blasting
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of him it was a lot of
emotion riding on that
man I had um you know recently lost my
mom before that fight and I was kind of
you know I was just on one I was in a
little tailspin for a minute so they
reached out to me it was like I needed
something at the time and they hit me up
asking me if I wanted to fight here at
home and I was like I'm with that you
know and they uh they offer me my guy
man I knew they were trying to build my
garment up and I thought and I'll dust
my gun Oh like I mean let me let me get
that way so I actually had a three fight
deal with them but I told myself and I
told my family this would be the last
one going into it and I just walked away
from the contract on a win and I just I
purely did that last fight just to kind
of like vindicate myself you know what I
mean I just had to feel like I was on
top one more time and I got is it that
was it he was like 6 1 he's a lot bigger
than the big dude yeah I was really I
was a big underdog on that one man and
he was kind of he was bumping his gum a
little bit you know in interviews and
stuff I was a lil he'd go to this a
little bit man they tried to snake me on
one interview where you know we're
talking on on the interview whatnot and
then like he's on the phone too while
they're asking me questions about him
and [ __ ] you know that oh by the way
Mike's on the phone now I'm like oh shut
up
yeah I'm like okay well I said it you
know that's what I'm gonna do so it was
a big win man it was a good fight I was
actually losing the fight I lost the
whole first round and we kind of knew
that was gonna be the case that he was
gonna come out go hard for a first round
and he private gasp cuz it away cut and
well he kind of jumped in really awkward
into your head he did and he got cry he
did and yeah just add a little extra
little sugar today man that was like
that extra like told you bro
what was he saying what was he saying
prior to you guys fighting um you know
that I just never fought at that level
you know he's been in the UFC and I'm
like man you know I've broke into the
top ten you know I went and beat some
very formidable opponents and here's the
thing about me you know win or lose
you're not gonna fight me twice I always
tell people that like you're you could
beat me but I'll guarantee you you won't
say running back
thank you yeah yeah and he was one of
those guys you know and I was like that
retired him that was it they actually
put the I was on this the Netflix thing
came out called the hurt business they
were talking about that whole deal and
that whole fight and who's that was that
documentary about it was actually about
the injuries in the sky lighted yeah I
heard that fools brain fluid yeah yeah
yeah they made me out to be a [ __ ]
ville they me would call me and asked me
about the [ __ ] that was a coal part oh
really
they could have called and asked me I
could have told them that I felt
terrible cuz I feel terrible my family
no I felt what was great about that job
you know it once it was over I was like
five you know cuz he had it actually go
to surgery from the arena like we gotta
take you in right now to go fix some
[ __ ] and once I saw the documentary I
thought man they really played me out to
be the bad guy yeah and didn't give me
no chance to like talk about it and say
how I felt cuz I didn't feel bad about
it and you know my family felt bad about
it is like hey Mia we don't want to see
that happen to you so I think you should
retire that was my mother-in-law she
said I love this she hated it at first
but she became one of my biggest fans
yeah can't stand it at first and after
that fight she said I just don't want to
see that [ __ ] happen to you you know I
physically can't watch a friend fight
it's hard so after I started just people
start going to MMA and then like even
watching like like so Andre sukham
taught right like after I met him in
person we started conversing with each
other after that it was hard for me to
watch him fight really it's just my
stomach starts to turn yeah like I get
nerves
I get nervous for the nerves it's like
I'm in the cage and I'm like yeah like
when a buddy of mine Ron skulls they
when I saw him first no wrong you know
Ron we fought around twice
we made that back so Ron hits like a
[ __ ] hit his heart is here I'm not
gonna live me a funny Ron story man
because I know you know Ron and he
fought our boy this kid Chris Fajardo
out of our gym right him Iran in the
ring man and Chris sets Ron down like
saddened
out on my hell yeah we got him yeah they
were like you know he had beat our guy
before so he mocks him down crowd goes
crazy our guy runs over there to go
finish the fight right gets up cracks
our dude our guy goes down it was just
one of those [ __ ] fights man I was up
high emotionally oh we got it it was
like I did
aah and then Ron finished it but it was
one of those spectacular fight he's a
beast man I gotta I gotta give it to Ron
hits for a little guy he has heart I
think that's the thing that people don't
expect out yeah because he's a see the
smaller guy but everybody says the same
[ __ ] about him like it's like a [ __ ]
front it that's like me I'm the same
type of guy like I can hit you know and
that's what a lot of people don't want
to run up on that because it's pretty
crucial that yeah when we when I said I
was just watching that fight like I feel
like the the UFC has changed a lot in
terms of like damage that a fighter
takes towards the end of the fight did
you see that cool table fight recently I
didn't so CUDA l'abbé
his fight got stopped over the dumbest
thing ever he was kind of he was kind of
rope-a-doping a little bit just kind of
a just do he's pretending like he was
dazed okay weighing around playing
around and they were fighting Wow stop
the fight I forgot who the [ __ ] ref
was no no I'm my man hope I hope he
wasn't my boy he would never do that
yeah we're the best reps in the game
yeah yeah but it was literally the
dumbest thing I've ever seen and I've
never seen it like it I think it's
becoming more and more like this were I
think they're trying because the
company's getting bigger
I think this becomes it becomes a little
more serious when people get more
seriously hurt
yeah so he was just kind of like in and
out yeah but he got he got he got head
kick from what I remember and then he
got a little dazed he was still on his
feet
but he was still exchanging right and
then there was a couple more head kicks
but he blocked all of them a lot of
these hits were missed and then he was
kind of just pretending a little bit
just throwing a little haymakers and
they just stopped the fight and
everybody was like what the [ __ ] was
going on yeah it happens man I mean at
the end of the day coaches tell the
athletes look don't don't let them steal
it from you not tell the guy that if
you're gonna lose go out on your sword
if you want to win go in because that's
what this is in the sport like that
nobody's gonna give it to you
you got two people in there you know
fighting for the same thing and in most
cases what people don't know about this
sport is in terms of the money let's
just say you know you're getting paid
fifty thousand dollars to show up and
fight then you're gonna make another
fifty thousand dollars if you win so
they always dangle that little carrot in
the front so sometimes you know you get
those guys that go in and get after it
because they're like if I lose here
that's a $50,000 loss you know I mean
like you're still getting paid but they
always kind of have they incentivize it
like how to UFC do with the fight of the
nights now the knockout of the night so
they're trying to make for action you
know they're really trying to push the
action push the chaos push the
submissions which I like you know and
and in the UFC culture as opposed to
like Japanese mixed martial arts to
complete different yeah different
animals you know the the Japanese scene
they're a lot more into watching the
technique in respect you don't hear
people in the background talking I'll
[ __ ] him up and you know you don't hear
that in Annapolis other than when I
started watching the One Championship
when people when it was going to the
ground everybody's cheering their ass
off because I feel like they might be a
little more educated in the sport so
they could see what's happening they
respect it yeah they disrespect it and
they know what you're doing because a
lot of a lot of the people you know
overseas this is just really you know
interval it's in the fibers of what they
do over there you know when I fought in
Japan I'll never forget you know going
there to fight and walking out looking
around and in the front row there was
like six women I swear to god they look
like they had to be in their 90's and
they were front row watching MMA and I
was really dumbfounded by that [ __ ] I'm
like man this is cool as hell
he's my blood on them that just it was
hilarious I like that Antonia like you
see this yeah so every every culture is
different when it comes to martial arts
and I think we're we're driving it in
terms
of popularity and in terms of the
Hollywood factor in the sport but MMA is
worldwide man I've been all over to see
it and it's it's huge you know we just
we just made it Hollywood how did you
how did you feel like when you decided
to step away from fighting especially
after such a huge win like that I feel
like there's a lot of fighters that I
see on you on the UFC they they say that
then we're tired then they get that huge
win and they're like I ain't done yeah
yeah I was on that for a minute I
thought about it and then you know the
the business part kicked in and then it
was like alright do I still want to like
go back to dine-in and [ __ ] do I want to
live that like it was pretty heavy you
know for me to like maintain being in
shape you know I like to eat I like to
enjoy a beer like I like to be me and
I've done it so long I was over the
whole you're a different person when
you're a fighter I think like you know
you don't really like to be bothered I
would come home sometimes I want to be
bothered you just kind of edgy all the
time and then you just banged up you
know you go through the there at the you
know repetitive like my back hurts my
shoulders hurt now this is hurt and I
just was kind of tired of that and I
think you know up more so I I felt
validated already you know I mean I felt
like what else am I gonna prove if I
don't make a run to be a champion right
now I'm just gonna be a journeyman type
guy that you know I'm not gonna gain
nothing over beating some guys unless it
was the right fight maybe but I didn't
really have much more to gain nobody
could take away any of the career that
I've had nobody could say that I was not
a legit fighter you know like I had all
those accolades that allowed me to do
what I'm doing now without any questions
so I felt like unless some of the
youngsters get in there and do it let me
be kind of like a mentor to them and and
and train other kids to come up you know
like I trained Nick and Heinrich and all
those guys like I meant toward them from
young now I probably met Nick at 18
Heinrich at
18 to hell they were young boys you know
here and I'm homeless as [ __ ] lately
many they shave that goddamn yeah but I
felt I fell into this role and and and
it feels good like I do like it and the
thing that I get to do now is I get to
beat up on them and they can't complain
you know I mean like here it is the old
retired coach out of shape still in here
kicking your ass and you can't really
complain about it at all you know so I'm
alright with that this podcast is
brought to you by fiber shall we talk
about finding freelance
talent for your business or project it
can be hard and time-consuming but
thanks to fiber it doesn't have to be a
struggle what kind of service can you
find on fiber I don't know copywriting
web programming film editing graphic
design there's so much more because it's
a freelance jungle out there
and fiber will help you navigate through
it it is that easy to find someone and
get what you need I have used fiber to
help me find graphic designers for album
art even helped develop many designs for
my business ventures it's so easy and
straightforward a David so can do it now
take five and check out fiverr.com and
you will receive 10% off your first
order by using my code GB it's so easy
don't waste any more time and get the
service you deserve by going to five-0
com code GB Fiverr it starts here did
you um did you ever feel like you you
really wanted like a championship belt
around your waist was that was that a
huge goal in mind when you were fighting
you know what man the funny thing is if
it came about I was ok with it but it
never was really like my ultimate goal
like I was just trying to eat man
honestly I was trying to eat take care
of my kids I got two kids you know so we
were trying to build a family and to pay
for a family through fighting was tough
as [ __ ] hmm so I was more or less just
trying to stay busy you know make sure
that I stay consistent with fighting
you know and one good company that that
helped me out was when I fought for the
International fight week when I fought
for this league which is kind of like
what's the other team went out PFL pfl
yeah yeah so it's like it was like the
PFL before the PFL even happened this
was in old 7 wait I think it was and
they paid us a salary monthly you know
they took care of us so we had that we
went they got a sponsor so it was really
like a good good deal for me and I was
eating I was eating out taking care of
myself
and I didn't really care about the belts
I just was a fighter and that's like oh
you want me to fight him ok cool he
thinks he think he can beat me ok line
it up you know once I broke into the top
10 I kind of thought like man I'm in the
top 10 right now maybe I can you know do
a little more and I took a tough ass
fight right after I got to the top 10
you know I beat a I fought Takashi in a
way who was ranked number two in the
world at least I'm okay
I beat him he was ranked right under
your eye of Faber they was trying to
make that fight at the time you know it
I choked him out oh [ __ ] yeah I choked
him out and right after I beat Takashi
anyway I probably fought I fought a mark
ha Manik maybe uh I don't know five
months after that you know and that was
a really tough fight when they did that
big affliction show oh yeah yeah yeah
the Honda Center hmm and I lost that
fight so then I was kind of like in a
little tails man like I don't know if I
wanna do it or not and you know but yeah
I never never really you know really
like won me over trying to be a champion
do you think that's an important factor
for somebody to be successful in
fighting is for them to actually go for
the belt or because I feel like I wonder
what that with the driving force is for
a lot of people right just because now
that that that belt comes with a lot of
things now it's not just the belt it's
like sponsorships right big money right
it's everything it's legacy yeah I think
looking at it now now that I look at
look back at it I probably wouldn't
some of the decisions that I made in the
sport and probably could have aligned
myself a little better you know for
instance I think my second fight as a
professional I fought against Chris
Lytle who was you know I think like 25
and 2 at the time you know but me you
know I'll come from the neighborhood I
was down the fight whatever he [ __ ]
put in front of me and I took fights
like that you know if I said I thought I
could win and I could have because I've
always I was always one punch away from
being a champion you know like I'll and
one shot that that's what it was gonna
be so looking back at it yeah maybe I
could have structured it a little bit
different but then at the same time you
know champions come and go and sometimes
they're just not the best champions and
I think in my era I might not have been
the best champion you know some people
are they're just not ready for it you
know they're not ready for you look at
like a John John some people aren't
ready for that
limelight hidden pregnant women and the
Coppa [ __ ] like we're not ready for it
you know and me I was more of a like I
just it took care of me so I respected
it because it allowed me to not put on a
suit and tie yeah you know and as long
as I can do that
I was cool that's interesting cuz
sometimes like I watch the sport and I'm
I'm kind of curious to see where it's
gonna go because it's starting to become
more and more like WWE which I I kind of
don't like yeah I mean there I mean they
know why it's doing a good job of
creating like these super fights which
is really cool like this coming up
coming weekend well we have Shang with
the the I [ __ ] love her she's a beast
okay I don't know her name fully but
she's a [ __ ] I should know her name
I'll keep [ __ ] it up dog [ __ ] though
I think she's gonna look Johanna's ass
that's what I think I think I think you
want is just on the she's on the down in
right now I mean she's been kickboxing
for how many years you know so even
though she's she's been an MMA for a few
years but she's been kickboxing wait
long time yes so she's taking a lot of
damage over the years you know I'm
curious about this fight and I'm curious
about the Romero fight you know and I
saw Damien I think I saw
okay case in point we got also dinya
right now who's like oh I'm written
Portia's for every day of my training
counseling up in a new car and I'm doing
this in that and I get it part of that's
cool but then you got a kid like yo
Romero I don't know if you know his
story or not but you know y'all Romero
was one of those kids Cuban wrestler
yeah like you gonna be a wrestler and
we're gonna send you to wrestling camp
when you're nine and don't come back and
tell you a champion that's insane
and literally like that's the story
there you know like they sent him away
to a camp like he lived there till he
was you know he was a world champion
don't come home if people don't know who
y'all will note the I'm his nickname is
soldier of God but this man has no
[ __ ] neck a he has no [ __ ] neck
AIDS animal I've never seen somebody get
head kick like six times and then he's
fine ya know this is this was a good
fight I'll say this if yo Romero doesn't
get knocked out in the first two rounds
he can win the fight if it doesn't go
past three mm-hmm because yo Romero we
all know yo Romero got a lot of muscle
on them and that [ __ ] requires some
cardio yes and he's notorious for you
know gas and to some extent so it's
crazy cuz I saw you know with the Robert
Whittaker fight I was surprised he got
knocked out yeah with a clean shot right
to the chin and you know that last fight
I thought Robert Whittaker [ __ ] did
not win that fight I thought y'all well
had it when it was your own like I was
kind of shot yeah so you know to see
Robert Whittaker get knocked out like
that I wonder if that's gonna I don't
see you all remember ever get knocked up
yeah that's gonna be good it's gonna be
a good fight man I mean I like acidemia
I remember when I was uh before he even
went to the UFC I was in Australia and a
buddy of mine was telling me about him
showing me videos and about yeah and I
was like man this dude right here bro
it's [ __ ] and then he just started
making that run you know and it and
nowadays if you can string up ten wins
you're something special
yeah you know what I mean like you're
special
you're talking about title contention
now you know and for me it wasn't like
that you had to you had to beat who's
who you had to like you know have some
illustrious record tree and get into the
UFC mm-hm
now I see guys getting into the UFC with
seven fights each total you know like oh
you got seven fights to your name as a
professional and three of those fights
might have been at like gladiator
challenge you know today where they
pulling dudes out the [ __ ] seats
right and now you in a UFC so the game
is weird there's some killers out there
I do know that there's good guys I come
from good camps but then there's a lot
of fluff there's a lot of fluff out
there you know and some of them don't
make it to UFC some do they'll get their
one shot and and then that's that man I
get kind of shocked when I see UFC
fighters go from they go to UFC to
Bellator and and then they start getting
belts it's like what the [ __ ] is going
on like is is the UFC caliber that
[ __ ] high like because I mean we have
people like like Douglas Leeman I'm
right he's just a beast I think you put
him in the UFC right we'll see what's up
absolutely you put Douglas Raymer in the
UFC I mean [ __ ] if you bring I mean give
Paul Daley another chance
oh man that [ __ ] was so dumb dear Bailey
a chance man like he's a good athlete
like you gave Tito a chance multiple
after they had beef and [ __ ] you know so
Paul de Leeuw wasn't pulling on numbers
probably so and he had one little
incident that I thought in the heat of
the moment this is the fight business
dude like shit's gonna happen because
Paul deli but what he punched it was
after the bell he punched what's he
thinking it was Koscheck right blanket
laying frank on yeah and you know
Koscheck was doing the whole fake you
know faking his injury township which he
did a couple of times arawa hated him
he was in the first season of The
Ultimate Fighter right yes and I did not
like him on that show he was the worst
and you know I think a lot of people
were upset because he would just lay on
people the whole time Holly did which
you know wrestling is fine but you got
to do something I mean it's MMA let's at
least throw a punch to wrestle yeah
and he would just go straight for the
wrestle like come on dude and then
afterwards when he's when he faked he
did that a couple times actually and I
was like I got no respect anymore come
on man and Paul de Leeuw I like Paul de
Leeuw is a killer well he got that
nyquil in his hand that's why man is a
killer man I really he's one of my
favorite guys Paul de Leeuw out I love I
think you would have I wish he was able
to still stay in the UFC but they just
kicked him out like that and I thought
that was a waste I've got you know what
I think what the UFC does well is they
know how to pick fights they know how to
match the right people together if they
don't like you for instance okay let's
say you get you come from Bellator or
you come from one if you know one FC and
your ear whatever you are there and they
don't like you they will purposely bring
you to the UFC just to see you get beat
up case in point
yes Ben Askren okay Dana white [ __ ]
hated him
mmm but he signed him you don't know why
because he wanted the world to see him
almost dying a ring you know so hey it's
it's a business and and styles make
fights and if you put the right people
together you get certain fights so I'm
curious about this Romero thing you know
this is the styles make fights type of
match so if one person can implement his
game we got one thing and then if Romero
can implement his game
we got another the the truth every what
I think is gonna happen is Romero
although I feel he can beat this right I
think he's gonna get sucked up into
trying to strike what I said a Mia and
get put down hmm
if he doesn't cuz I know I said then he
doesn't have the best wrestling that's
not menacing he's a striker by trade and
he's only been taken down like once no
wonder people right because he has good
movement
he has great movement you know he but I
mean you know he is gonna be in there
with yo Romero who I think it's a
different different piece that's a
different animal in terms of takedown
you know I know he fought Whitaker I
knew Anderson Silva when I'm taking him
down and all the other guys you know so
if we had somebody that we could
consider a formidable opponent in terms
of taking them down I think el Romero's
a lot of Sonia takes down Yoel Romero
like I think that kind of solidifies his
like validity right absolutely because I
mean one or is it it's just like he's
fighting like the he wants top people to
which is what I really appreciate it
yeah it doesn't he doesn't duck fights
he goes well I'll fight you but you
can't I'm not just gonna do it at a drop
of a hat like right like let's set this
[ __ ] up I get a training camp I will
[ __ ] you up remote it gets a little UFC
embedded you know do the whole little
the little hype show because he knows
who he wants he wants he wants a after
Romero he wants to go against Paulo
Costa ok wish that [ __ ] if he's
not on the gear or roids at all I don't
know what the [ __ ] is in the water yeah
yeah he is an animal he don't look human
at all yeah you know man the sport is
evolved though honestly the sport just
like any other sport you look at you
know athletes you look at bodybuilders
back in the day you look at him now you
look at the sport itself
you know we had BMX now we got X game
you had boxing you know in wrestling now
we got MMA so the sports just progressed
and then you got kids that are younger
and younger that are setting out to do
this as a profession so when you get
that you got these crazy-ass parents
that are elitist you know I'm gonna put
my son to go train and this he's gonna
wrestle we're gonna just take him out of
school at home school um I got no
parents that do that well with kids like
we're gonna take our kids out of school
because they're gonna be jiu-jitsu
champions and I'm like man you just
really you know are structuring your
kid's life I was almost one of them I
was trying to do that with my son yeah
like you're gonna be a boxer we're just
gonna go on this run and it wasn't
really what he wanted to do but I had it
in my eyes this is what you got to do so
these kids now physically they're
tougher they're getting high-level
training that has evolved over the years
you know whether it be wrestling jujitsu
Muay Thai you know done with the days of
the like courage and respect honor ride
a gym these kids in here like brah [ __ ]
you up man
we're not playing that no more so that
the games changed like I'm curious to
see where this were to be at in the next
15 years like where what type of
athletes are gonna be out there I mean
the athletes out right now just blow my
[ __ ] mind to just somebody like like
Mighty Mouse like he he doesn't make any
sense at all I mean where's the hole in
this game I think right right what hole
does he have in his [ __ ] game right
when he got traded off the one of how
was that
I would you know I thought that was the
place for him is it better look I mean
they have they have more people in his
weight class that he's better yes a way
better look for him and they're giving
him some trouble over there too in that
easy fights you got all these kids
coming from Thailand you know you got
some real strikers in one Fc
you know we just had a guy that he lost
unfortunately you know one of my boys he
kind of reps the gym a little bit
this kid mu stuff well he fought against
Akiyama I don't know if he saw Owen or
not I did see him but I know a yeah yeah
he was whooping ah knocking I was asked
for a second then uh yeah qiyamah
collingsgood missile but that's the
thing though that it could always change
in a fight like you you never know
that's why like I think like betting on
MMA fights are one of the scariest yeah
it is
Michelle's right know what's gonna I
don't know you don't know what's gonna
happen and it's the it's so sporadic you
know you can slip on a banana peel and
this into your [ __ ] mas Fidel was
gonna get wrestled to the floor by
[ __ ] ass and I was one of those people
I was like man why did you put him in
here with Ben Askren and man when he
went over there just when I saw the
Robbie Lawler fight between Astrid and I
arguably thought that he was knocked out
and I thought they were just gonna call
the Fowler's mad at that one I was a
little like my boy referee that he was
knocked out I was like how come I call
this yeah I thought they were gonna stop
that one yeah honestly and then when I
was like I got so upset because I was
like that's not an L on Robbie laughs
that's not a L I'm which I thought they
should've fought again for sure
now don't ask me no others
you know he did not want that smoke
again like I said you know you may win
but you're not gonna fight me exactly
that's what Robbie Laughlin's it you
know who you know your fighting style
actually kind of reminds me of Jeremy
Stephens oh yeah yeah Jeremy stammered a
little bit too man that's my boy like
people always look at Jeremy Stephens
and they say like he doesn't have the
best fighting record but I guarantee you
he gets asses in seats Carl I want to
see him fight every time he's he comes
he goes the last fight was great too and
that's what I could do goes man he
scares the [ __ ] out of me yeah
he's the the funny thing about Jeremy's
dude he's one of the coolest [ __ ]
dudes man like cool like sit down and
chop it up with you man ask her about
the fam I'm just cool when I buy your
life like cool dude man you wouldn't
think he is such a killer like he is
like you would just think he's that dude
I mean don't talk to him don't don't do
that with Jeremy Stephens he's like way
cool I would never see that because when
he's in that cage he looks like a serial
killer yeah [ __ ] yeah when he when he
fought even when he fought Aldo and he
lost because that body shot he was doing
well yes he was piecing up although
pretty hard he really was and it's just
that first of all all those hands are
the size of my face oh well why the [ __ ]
is his hand so it was like Mickey Mouse
hey look pretty damn good his last right
- I gotta say I mean he lost that one -
I wasn't set I was upset I don't think a
single person was happy with that I was
upset there's been a lot of [ __ ] weird
calls like I don't understand what's
going on in the UFC right now well you
know it depends on where you fight you
know when you go to like Texas for
instance you know you got boxing refs
that are doing MMA and a lot of these
dudes don't like MMA I remember fighting
in Texas hearing them say ya know how
come they on the ground so long how come
how come they're doing this why are you
always wrestling why don't they just get
up fight you know really it's crazy man
so it's not and these dudes are like
they don't leave from the Commission man
until they retire or die or some [ __ ]
like a lot of these guys are a long time
like you know we still got gene LeBell
you know we still got gene LeBell judge
and fight
I love them as if but you can't be
judging them or fights can even see how
old is he made me sign some autographs
you know I mean check the check love's
do something else yeah be a part of the
sport but don't you can't make a break
because some of these guys are really
not necessarily damaging the careers but
like you may be on your way and you get
a bad call and then you don't get that
title shot cuz you lost the fight due to
something so go backwards yeah you gotta
have competent rest for one judges 100%
did you watch that that wilder fight
though with the with mr. Tyson Fury oh
yeah I did man that was that was hard to
watch for me you know I mean I like them
both I'm not gonna lie I like Tyson Fury
I think he's good for the sport you know
what I mean he's a proper - you know
proper Englishman you know he looked
like me he's not the typical like
prototype fighter but he can thump dude
and I'm okay with that
you know and Wilder is uh you know he's
rash he he has duck I love that about
him you know and he's a killer
I mean you seen his record and 40k owes
every fight by kail the hey oh my who
has that kind of record insane so I was
a little surprised by the fight and then
you know all the hype afterwards all the
the conspiracy theories that are out so
now they're talking about um Tyson's
gloves you don't know if you see now
well they were saying oh that was from
the first match though right I know I
said in both that Samoa
that he was doing that flicker jab with
the loose gloves saying that the padding
was out or some [ __ ] it's always
something you know and then of course
while they're talking about I actually
agree with wilder on the [ __ ]
transformer suit yeah what the [ __ ] was
that if [ __ ] was he doing dude I'm like
you didn't man it was terrible well I
thought it was I mean first of all I
well I heard about this from somebody
else but they said that on the Joe Rogan
podcast he says that he trains with the
45 pound vest and it's red and it feels
like nothing to him so
lying like what so when he said that
it's like yo you already put it out
publicly that forty five pounds is
nothing uh it's like a grain of rice
yeah
and so you got that [ __ ] and then you
come out looking like I don't know
bejeweled I don't know it I don't know
what the hell is that I was mad at him
no yeah you know what the funny thing is
when I see fighters do that that's like
yo just wait til you losing that [ __ ]
suit look mad goofy exactly so so when I
walked when I watched the walkout I
thought man Tyson is being carried to
the ring he's not wasting the [ __ ]
drop of energy smart smart man I say
he's just floating to the ring right now
and then I watch this jackass walk out
with a suit on dude
and I'm going man what is this suit you
wear it you know and I don't know if it
was heavy or what damn you're 50 pounds
but Tyson's in the ring this whole time
chillin loosening up getting ready
talking to his coaches getting
instruction you know I mean he's already
kind of doing this little ring walk and
you know Wilder just had to jump in on
suit let's go and that's what we got
that's a guy I mean what was his coach's
thinking though I mean I think about
that because I mean I don't know I don't
know about the coaching side but I feel
like if I was in somebody's corner and I
said hey get that [ __ ] suit off you
know it's 50 [ __ ] pounds and warm up
properly because this is about to be the
fight of your life you're fighting for
you to defend your belt I'll tell you
what if I was his coach he wouldn't wear
that [ __ ] period I would have like cut
all the gimmicks you're the champion
okay you haven't lost don't just go in
there and do your job that's it like
[ __ ] the little hype show like I know he
does it every fight but like be like
Mike Tyson man Mike Tyson used to walk
out with the towel over his head man
ready to kill somebody Mike Tyson was
and then I because I wasn't in the
boxing at the time so everything I've
seen of Tyson was after he retired so I
didn't get to live a lot of his file
live that man it was such a great time
and then sometime it wasn't because it
was only like 40 seconds and we had
I heard people I forgot which way it was
but it was like a ten second fire god
yes
could they pay so much money yes but
what did you expect from Tyson Tyson
wasn't a knock people out I think what I
loved about Tyson from what I said when
I saw later on was because when I watch
people like wilder and Wilder he's a
he's a knockout artist right right but
sometimes I don't like watching a box
because his shit's ugly as [ __ ] it's
ugly
trash he lands one is over but exactly
and that's what he's really counting on
because he has that really quick one too
and so when I see it up into the point
before he knocks somebody out is very
undertake because I'm not seeing any art
- right right no art but it's not like
when you see Loma chanko fight right you
see Loma chanko fight you're excited
you're like okay this is good yeah this
is a another good boxer that I like that
he just took a loss to this kid I forgot
his name but I wanted to see him fight
lomachenko and there's his kid named
Tevin farmer
oh wait evan farmer who'd hoody fight he
I can't remember the kid's name but I
heard he lost a decision to a local kid
some kids from like Whittier or
something like that and and I can't
[ __ ] name
but Tevin farmer it was another one of
my favorite boxers he has that slickness
about him he reminds me of like a
Pernell Whitaker hmm you know just has
that game and I wanted to see him either
fight a lomachenko or like agra Vontae
ooh
Davis I wanted to see those matchups but
he lost so you know now you're gonna
have to work his way back up the ladder
you know then you also got people like
Devin Haney that's coming up - and Devin
Haney's interesting me yes how I
described Devin Haney from what I've
seen like just from like I've seen like
maybe three of his fights
you remind he has at that Mayweather
defense anybody hits like a Russian dude
but he hit like a rush again now you can
put you down yeah at 100% so there's
there's some good fights out there man
and boxing is starting to come around
the corner MMA to me you know I think is
the pinnacle of fight sport because you
see it all you see the wrestling you see
the the ground in town but if you wanted
to well late kicks just open up and
everything completely different guys you
got you got four limbs to worry about
that's the hard part and the thing
that's tougher than both of those and a
lot of people don't realize this and
that's kickboxing kickboxing is tougher
than MMA kickboxing is a more brutal
sport than MMA it's like I enjoy MMA but
we have our outs yeah you know we have
our like oh man he's kicking my ass I'm
gonna take him down to do the check you
know I have to and that's part of MMA
yeah
kickboxing you're gonna take that Fame
bro like you're gonna do that fate
you're tired they're not gonna they're
not gonna you know they don't just stop
the fights you get put down then they
stop the fight so and I've noticed I've
been in a Europe watching kickboxing in
like Eastern Europe some of these other
countries they can't stand MMA they they
really don't like MMA I went out so I
was in Romania for some kickboxing and
they found out that we were MMA guys
they're like oh you know they kind of
laughed at it like MMA guys you guys
aren't tough and I was like damn just
cause that [ __ ] it on our [ __ ] you know
and I would watch the fights and I'm
going to him you know I don't know if I
would want to stay in there and take
that type of an ass woman without having
any options that's because it's like
that Dutch kickboxing style to like me
when they spar it's like you would have
thought the guy raped his mother yeah
that's your friends not like Muay Thai
it's like it's a different ballgame
Dutch kickboxing a different ballgame
that's kind of like Marc's style the
kickboxing that I like and let's go
let's go there's no elbows or nothing
that's like we're gonna punch kick and
me it's insane when I saw how hard they
spar man that was something else
that's just drilling really you know
like back and forth for power kicks for
power punches you know especially the
guys from like Mike's gym I don't know
if you heard of Mike's gym that's a gym
out and you know they're out in
Amsterdam and those dudes are killers
man like their careers aren't real long
because you know they beat the [ __ ] out
of each other in practice all the time
but when it comes to intensity and and
just turnover
you know these dudes man they they're
the best at it if you if you were to
give like advice to somebody who wanted
to start fighting because I think
there's a lot of people who are
interested in fighting right but I feel
like a lot of the times people don't
know what it takes to be an actual
fighter because it's really glorified
right and when we see a lot of people
who who are now doing the whole you know
the flashy [ __ ] right you got your Kobe
coming Tanner's you know even on to
Sanya he's he very flashy with this [ __ ]
but he has the pedigree to back it up
right I guess like what would be your
advice to somebody who who wants to be a
pro fighter like what would they start
what would they do
well I honestly think in today's era of
fighting where we're at now
fighters are already being groomed young
you got kids that are going from like
sage Northcutt exactly like their their
Jiu Jitsu kids or their kids like Said's
I might have came up doing karate or
whatever it may be they're doing
wrestling in high school they're doing
wrestling in college and then they start
figuring ok what am I gonna do after
college try MMA or try some sort of
fighting I think gone are the days of
I'm tired of working this nine-to-five I
think I'm gonna give this MMA thing a
try unless you are a [ __ ] phenom of
an athlete mean Angela hill or something
like that you got it yeah you have to be
on a level you know and you have to have
this athleticism and I think it's
different for women I think the door is
still open for women to just say hey I
want to be a fighter and they may be
able to put five years in a train and it
may be able to make a run but I think
you know on the male side of it if
you're not a kid that has some sort of
aspiration to be a fighter you it's
gonna be hard-pressed for you to make it
far so you know I say depending on how
far you want to go you may be like a
lower-level fighter you know to me like
I'm not trying to crush nobody dreams or
nothing be trying to put the perspective
in there yeah just to put it on what
what you want to do that you know and
for me you know I got a lot of people
that come into the gym that wanna fight
and I always tell myself I am not the
one to deny anybody from their goal of
fighting so I'm realistic with him right
out the gate
case in point Heinrich I remember
Heinrich came to me at 18 years old and
said hey I want to be a pro fighter no
experience I say you know what honestly
men it's probably gonna be about five
years five six years before you get a
check for fighting Jesus he said he was
with it you know that's why I love him
to death he was with it he took all the
bumps and bruises all the training you
know he was really good as an amateur he
fought for like a state championship you
know we went in there and you got [ __ ]
head kicked in 30 seconds and we lost
that yeah we were driving back home from
San Jose it was ok though you know funny
funny story you know it was a crazy
story that that fight these dudes were
young and I had my own room and [ __ ] so
I'm kind of chillin like man you know
however you need to be resting man and
get some rest I go over here these dudes
in there he wasn't but they in there
partying and [ __ ] got a bong and [ __ ] in
yeah oh my man you know this dude
fighting for a title tomorrow these guys
are all party and he trying to sleep so
I had to go get him out of his room
bring him in there with me man and you
know and he lost the fight but he had
that drive to say win or lose I'm gonna
play the game yeah and not everybody has
that you know not everybody has that
ability to show up after you lose like
everybody's cool when they win you see
the dude that went in the gym next day
right pull up he's good he's getting off
his little that's Augustine that'd
probably be me like if I get one quit be
the fighters angry right now I have no
fights I'm an undefeated professional
but it's hard man like I went through
that you know I would lose fights and
people would be like man you lost how'd
you lose to him or you know people are
their City yeah man they're real shitty
you know I've had my own family like
that like how'd you lose it you know and
and you
you let him beat you I had to do
something hey man I lost money on you I
say that's really okay I got my ass beat
thanks a lot yeah you should have told
me who you been for what kind of
question is that like come on is that
criticism kind of hard to take when
you're a fighter is that mom I mean it's
like anything now you know like
everybody got an opinion everybody got
an opinion everybody feels like you
should or would or you should have did
this or it's always the armchair
quarterback like it's always somebody
that has something to say cuz I'm not a
fighter I get annoyed about that [ __ ]
it's like you you know like just
training a little bit and then some is
like a try this is like why aren't you
coming to show me right let's see I mean
I've watched you start it I've watched
you come in I watched you when you were
just starting out on it you literally
saw me at the beginning beginning you
know but also what I will say I seen you
do as I seen you continue to try to get
better like I seen you work on your own
like I was seeing you messages like hey
man do this or that you know cuz I was
seeing you trying to eat you know so I'm
like man we got to feed this dude
because it helped out a lot though I was
like got it well I mean I knew you were
a lefty that switched yeah you know I
mean like I was like oh that's cool he
went he went riding and I think that's
cool it's worked out better for you you
know down the line so people just got a
you just got to push those and feed
people I want to do it and I respect the
fact that you're doing it because for
one a lot of people just say they do it
yeah to a certain extent but they never
really are willing to like nuts I'm not
saying go be a fighter but you've put on
gloves you spar you've been hit you
you've done it you know you take the
bumps and bruises and you keep doing as
a hobbyist
now when you say hey I want to make that
transition then we lay out a whole
different game plan you got a whole
different style of training you got a
whole different group of people you
probably training with because now it
becomes we're trying to prepare you not
only to win a fight we're ultimately
training and I get hurt and that's the
mark that people miss they always think
it's about the win
the fight I'm like the wind comes from
the work but what you try to do is avoid
getting hurt cuz I've seen many very bad
injuries that people don't see in the
game you know and that's the part of it
that you know you don't wanna you don't
want to wake up Monday like man this
happened to me and I got my arm but I've
seen dudes get the jaws broke arm broke
orbitals broke you know it's multiple
fractures and see you know I mean so
it's it's a it's a tough game and you
know it's glorified but it's really
brutal and I think not everybody should
do it just because they feel you know
they woke up one Monday thinking it's
cool to do I think it's very smart to
kind of put that into perspective for
people too because you know just to go
back to that advice part it's like I
think when people want to be a pro
fighter they don't understand the scope
of what it is to be a pro fighter they
don't understand how difficult it is one
of the biggest reasons why I wanted to
do like kick boxing and Muay Thai was
because I kind of I wanted to understand
the sport a little more right and it
actually made watching the UFC a lot
more fun because absolutely I could see
you know what's going on before I'm just
like I didn't know what was going on and
just waiting for a knockout right but
now I see hand traps I see say you see
setups yeah you see like ok I think this
round he's gonna try this you know you
appreciate it more does it want to be
like a Steven Naismith you know he's
like [ __ ] punching dicks man he
pissed me off with that he pissed
everybody off
oh my guys either it's like yo when you
don't know [ __ ] just say you don't know
[ __ ] it's ok yes ok you don't know it
he called Donald Cerrone a quitter I was
like I've never heard anybody say oh my
god I was mad dude I like you cannot
come in here with that 100% it was so
odd because I was like you literally
sound like you've never watched the UFC
ever command I was pissed off at him I
was I was on some like if I ever see him
a heavy on TMZ I mother run up on his
ass he just didn't get it either because
you know Conor McGregor came at him said
you should apologize for that [ __ ] yeah
even Joe Rogan was speaking about that
and he was like I'm in a professional
commentator what about
for a full year I don't mean [ __ ] bro
nothing like you've never been punched
in the face you've never trained in that
type of well he trained you started
really
we got the video leaked that [ __ ] was so
funny and I thought he was just been
like yeah kind of spoke out of turn on
that but he just doubled down on he
going bad I might never bear that's
[ __ ] wild I was I was a little
shocked about that [ __ ] because when
somebody says Donald Cerrone is a
quitter that means you've never watched
the UFC you never watched it
they all know absolutely no way you
could say that this is a dude who will
fight three days in a row for no goddamn
reason you know I love Donald Cerrone
man I was really pulling for Donald
Cerrone I thought this was a terrible
fight for Conor McGregor I'm not gonna
lie oh really and I was like man Donald
Cerrone
you know me I'm oh Jesus I look at him
like [ __ ] this young dude up man get him
out of here you know when Donald Cerrone
went up a weight class he started
winning again I was super happy yeah
[ __ ] I was on board McDonald man he was
he was cracking all these kids who
thought that they could take him out
okay I'm trying to go through the
gatekeeper right now man
I really didn't see that going the way
it did and I think what happened was if
you remember that fight there was a
little me that blipped him like I saw
that he Jose yeah it's just little me
that blipped him and nobody really
noticed it but I think that was the
start of it it was just a one little
perfect little clip and he just couldn't
get his head back okay the only reason
why I assumed that I think like Cerrone
he just has a little bit of problem with
like head movement he takes too much
damage and when you have somebody as
surgical as Conor McGregor I just didn't
think that I mean not to knock on Conor
McGregor but he's going up a weight
class with some big boys yeah so I just
thought that he wouldn't have the power
to crack him like that for me you know
when I saw he was fighting Cerrone and
you mentioned sirot knees head movement
right so I just go back to the Nate Diaz
and I'm like maybe I absolutely no hair
movement or hands really and he was able
to touch Conor up you know what I mean
so I when I saw some wrong it make sense
I was
I'm answering he's not this is a rat
because you know when Nate Diaz fought
Conor McGregor I didn't actually this is
this is just for Steven Naismith just so
he could shut the [ __ ] up like he went
into that fight people don't even know
but he got kicked in his face by a horse
and he had a broken jaw he had a
fractured jaw and he took that fight
didn't get knocked out and he continued
it with a broken job with his mouth oh
yeah
crazy and I remember Joe Rogan he was
commentating he was like I think his
jaws broke yeah I was like I don't
because his mouth was constantly open
like definitely open yeah and he came
out after that he got kicked in the face
by a horse and he scores
yeah no he's the man man like you can't
take nothing away from that kid I just
want him to retire though honestly yeah
I think he's done he has like like I
said sometime you get to a point where
Donald Cerrone is gonna be down from her
own Eve with fighting or without
fighting
he doesn't need to you just need a belt
he doesn't need no bail
he doesn't need a belt there like he's
Donald Cerrone man like he's the belt
himself you know so I think nobody's
gonna look at him any different you know
and he's has I mean he's one of the most
celebrated guys in the sport I think you
know he just needs to give it a rest now
I'm surprised he's my height - yeah he's
finding a 155 yeah big boy yeah it's big
dude he's a big big dude that's another
one of the reason why I stopped doing it
man he's do just seem like they're just
bigger and bigger yeah like I don't
understand how sick people who are like
six two are hitting 155 I'm yeah what's
that
yes I was at a disadvantage and most
size-wise most fine you fought everybody
that even when I see you like I always
wait for the Saturday so I can see you
spar somebody and you always pick the
biggest person in the real quick you
know you know what it is man it's just
uh
that's just how I came up I came up
whatever it was never a oh you too big
for me I always felt like if you can't
fight you can't fight like big or small
it doesn't really matter you should have
a game for both you got a game for tall
guys
you got a game for short guys you know I
fight heavyweights we had a heavyweight
come in there I didn't even know this
guy with the heavyweight in the UFC and
I was like man it was pretty good man is
entering around pretty good it [ __ ] I
forgot his last me I think his last name
was Kimble yeah tip of my tongue it'll
come to me but anyway he was moving real
good they're like man you know he fights
in the UFC [ __ ] I wasn't here trying to
dust him off really like coming at him
and he had some game so I was like where
just do come from and he trained that's
his gym out in a Vegas he from a
syndicate gym he's actually have you
ain't current heavyweight oh wow yeah he
just came into the gym to get some work
he loved the gym he's like man it's a
great place we get so many bodies on
Saturdays man and that place is it's
crazy I get scared you know you asked me
to come through on my dude I'm serious
me you need to come in there bro
you do it I've seen some of the ladies
I'm like these ladies would [ __ ] me got
a couple dealers in there we got a
couple of them they are tough I'm not
gonna lie nice that's what I like man I
like the fact that you know I'm not
gonna say any names about gyms you know
but not serious enough
there's gyms out there that are making
these women feel that they know what
they're doing but they don't ever put
them in the real situation like you're
not gonna get good
just hit in the back you know like you
know that you gloved up pushing guards
on I see you work on your tools on the
back those are sharpening the tools we
got to go out there and shoot it as oh
it's it's a bag don't hit back at all
yeah you know and people miss that and I
tell the women that right away when they
come in I said everybody that for that
matter like look when you come in here
there's gonna be some days where you get
tested there's gonna be days where you
know you're gonna have to do some
trading because this is what we're here
to do now we're gonna do it in a
controlled environment for some people
new to spar and we say like our room is
broke up in sections right so we have
our people in the ring that are new to
sparring back everybody knows this
corner of the room people are fairly new
just starting to get their feet wet
sparring and then you move towards
middle of the room these kids are like
amateur fighters you know or very good
day-to-day practitioners and then you
got the other side of the room where I
tell people hey don't come over here
because yeah you know and we've had a
couple kids like we've had some and
really had a kid last week maybe two
weeks ago real crazy [ __ ] dude going
hard with a guy and he got his rear
broke I'm like hey man I told you not to
come over here that's that's one of
those things too that if I think that
kind of annoyed me too when I just
started going to random gyms and you
know people be kind of nice all right
but then like you're always gonna get
dished out what you give to me so it's
like period if if we're going light
right we're gonna keep it light right
but when you go full clip I'll go back
full clip like what what is this and
then I get pissed at this though like I
didn't this is the first thing when the
first time I experienced this I started
getting really [ __ ] mad it's like you
go with somebody right you start
exchanging and they start turning it up
right and then you crack him real hard
to go uh I'm real tired I'm like hold on
it you just tried to [ __ ] knock your
block off right and now you're tired
yeah you're not tired you got to get the
[ __ ] up you guys at this point like so
when I when I first started training
this guy invited me out - it was just I
can't remember which kickboxing gym it
was but it was it was it was like
towards like the North Hollywood like -
Hungaria okay it was some random gym and
at that point I just wanted to just work
out and so this guy's looks like light
spar a little bit and he just starts
throwing full clip at me and I think
it's because he knew I was like a
youtuber so he make like a little show
out of yeah because one of his buddies
was recording that's fine cuz I thought
he wanted to look at footage or whatever
I told the story to admit cuz I was
[ __ ] heated this is when I first
started training the first like five
months right and then you're a green
nose green yeah and this guy just
started but the one thing I learned how
to do was throw low kicks sounds like
cool so I just threw a full-on full clip
low kick right I just cracked him and
I'm I'm a heavier dude than him so he
didn't really like that that much he
didn't get back up so it's like and then
he got upset at me and I'm like hold on
a second man you literally try to knock
my teeth out you have a mouse on
and leg kicks are legal you go hard
everyone knows like you're not gonna
lose teeth if I kick your legs so I used
to get upset at that [ __ ] it's like you
got to realize like you get dish
whatever you give out you know those are
the rules I tell people that the rules
are hit as hard as you want to get hit
yeah that's it
some days we will have structured
sparring words like alright we're gonna
do offense and defense sparring
meaning all I can do is defend oh you
can do is attack we get good rounds out
of that because these are when guys are
getting ready for fights or we're trying
to work on some sort of specifics with a
certain person and it's just kind of a
good icebreaker like yeah you play
defense
I'll play offense you're gonna work on
your thing I work on mines and we're not
like clashing the whole time because
you've got you got guys that are trying
to like you know they in there swinging
swords right we're in there just trying
to see who hits harder or who's faster
or whatnot and you don't really get any
true work yeah because we're too busy
trying to win in the gym and and that's
what you got to get away from when
you're trying to win in the gym it
doesn't matter there yeah I feel like
there's there's people to that I've seen
where almost I've seen but I've heard
about these guys who are like gym
warriors but then when they get into the
games guy it's like what the [ __ ]
happened here the lights get to them or
something else but when they're
exchanging in the gym they just [ __ ]
people up there's a lot of them yeah
there's a ton of them and I don't know
what it is about those those guys like
me I was always ready to go and it was
time to go I was always ready in the gym
also can I consider myself a
professional and I think you should be
able to go anywhere and be formidable in
any environment you know some guys you
know like those dudes I need to get hit
before they fight I was never that guy I
hate getting hit I never wanted to get
hit I never believed in letting people
score on me for me to get some sort of
like inner hey come back with because if
that's the case you know you're not
gonna have a long career yeah yeah way
you know so I was always trying to be a
technician like I was down the scrap I
was always down the scrap but
i scrapped with that in mind of let me
not get hit like I've never been knocked
out I've probably fought well over 25
times and I've never been Kayode in the
fight and I don't ever wanna be because
it's not a good look that's why you
don't sound like James Toney and [ __ ] oh
my god James another one of my favorites
James Toney man like was hard to talk to
him it's man I don't know [ __ ] he's
saying it's impossible yeah it's pretty
sad actually it's it's I was like what
the [ __ ] happened man that yeah cuz
James Toney was amazing he was one of
the best but you can't talk to him now
you know and that that's the part of the
this these are the type of people that
some of these guys that are waking up
rolling up their bed saying they want to
be fighters they need to see these guys
yeah and make a real and make a real
decision you know make a real decision
on your career if you really want to do
this because it is a good thing it is
cool I mean I love fighting and what it
does but it's really not for everybody
on a professional level and you'll see
it you'll see that a lot of this too
because we were talking about how you
know there's a lot of things that you
could lie or [ __ ] about like
jiu-jitsu and kickboxing or two other
things that you cannot lie for [ __ ]
about because when you're on that mat
people will see what's up they do and
I've seen a lot of people lie about
their [ __ ] and you know for me like
because it is a hobby of mine and I
think I respect the sport a lot how I
always say to it's like if you tell me
that for example my mother put this
dude's name on blast but if you tell me
you have 20 [ __ ] amateur matches
right right and then you exchange with
somebody who's been kickboxing for a
year and I'm [ __ ] you up yeah that
means you have not had 20 matches
absolutely not you should actually
teaching me some absolutely teach me I'm
100% on board with it and you know it
kind of makes me upset because like you
just wasted my [ __ ] time and like I
wanted to learn something today you you
gassed yourself up you tell me so many
stories about yourself and now I want to
see it yeah not not to like disprove you
but I'm not I mean I'm hungry I want it
is I'm the same way yeah show me what
you're working with and if it's
something that I feel I'm like wow I'm
gonna ask about it I want to see what it
was maybe I can train and learn
something from you but yeah don't gas
yourself up and not have it and that's
one of the reasons
for ten years every Saturday we've had
open sparring at fight academy and it's
always been open door to every gym you
know how many local gyms I've invited to
come down there to get some work in that
don't come and I don't know why they
don't because it seems pretty funny it's
like oh look it's all love always you
know we have fun with shooting [ __ ] you
know we're talking about each other you
know we get little fights in the middle
where the gym are kind of slowed down
because these two dudes are going at it
pretty good so we'll kind of hype them
up on the side and and it's just all in
good fun and then all at the end we may
crack a beer and hang out and just talk
about what we were doing and what I
think is some gyms don't like to do that
because they feel well if we get showed
up right here then they might leave and
go to this gym but I'm like in in the
old school way of martial arts your gym
is your gym to it like you don't you
don't really bounce around like if you
train there if that's your home gym
that's your home gym you can go out and
train wherever you want to go train just
to get work but you always come back to
the hood man like that's your
neighborhood you know that's where you
that's the place you represent I can go
get work here go get work with these
guys but I have my home place and I
think people feel some sort of under
uneasy with being exposed by any other
place and so it's a it's a big pride
issue and it's it's also just kind of
like I think some people too they know
they have a bit of like smoke and
mirrors right and yeah and that's what
they're about so it kills your girls
you're not okay yeah like if you if you
come into a gym where people have active
fighters it's a different situation
right so you're not gonna be able to
come up here and tell your stories
you're not gonna be a yeah yeah yeah
none of that people don't want to hear
that so I don't want them flood they
want to see it they want they want to
see that exchange touch glove let's see
what you're working exactly that's why I
like you know I get beat up it's such a
great experience I'm like oh [ __ ] maybe
I can learn something from this guy but
let me tell you this I'm sure like you
saying beat up you might have gotten
touched up in around if you learned like
man I'm getting outpointed or I'm
getting out this but you're not leaving
like I got beat up like I had heard
that's not happy you know like my ribs
is fracture you know you're not not that
kind of beat up cuz back in the days
there would be those times I remember
coming home sometimes like what happened
you know like you know my wife would
look at me like yeah you sure you want
to do this like you here yeah like
what's wrong you know what is sparring
this is it's all light if somebody wants
to turn it up we'll turn it up you know
and sometimes you have what I found out
that I got I had to stop beating myself
up about it's like sometimes you have
good days and sometimes you have bad
days period just show up to work that's
what I tell people you have good bad
days in the office show up to work yes I
got to do Nick would always say to is I
you got to just stop getting mad at
yourself enough yeah well sometimes you
just have bad [ __ ] days that's it it
is what it is
you know and here's another thing that I
tell everybody and I sure this with you
too I think every sparring round that
you go into or you know you're getting
ready to have you need to have a goal
per round like you're going to around
saying I'm not gonna get tipped by
kinloch you're gonna happen either way
you gotta go into each round with the
goal of this is what I'm trying to
achieve this round now if my goal was to
land ten leg kicks and I landed ten leg
kicks but I ate four hooks that's okay
my goal was Landy's leg kicks so
whatever I did as as a prerequisite the
landing of leg kicks that was the good
part that was the stuff that I need to
remember so when I go out there and do
it with somebody else you know you're
proficient in that area but most people
just feel like they just want to win you
know that's like that's like the Black
Belt jiu-jitsu practitioner that don't
want to roll with lower belts because
they worry about getting subbed you know
me I'm like you shouldn't be getting
subbed by the motor belts you're at this
level you gotta mean like you should
know more you should be able to
manipulate them in a way that they're
not even used to based on your
experience that's how I am with sparring
like I'll go in there and spar with
whoever move with whoever make people
miss they're like man how you do that
I'm like well it's so repetitive for me
like most people make and I don't want
to say the same mistakes but I kind of
know how to play my car
you play the game that I want you to
play with me and I yes and then I teach
them that that's the beauty of to what I
do like I'll do certain things and
didn't put them to the side and be like
hey I did this I did that you should
probably watch out for these things you
know this type of guy does this so
sparring should be a like learning
environment and if you're not spawn
you're really not learning how to fight
yeah I think that was the the biggest
thing that I wanted to to do eventually
was when I was starting training was
like I got to see what it's like to get
hit in the face
consistently it's like um like street
brawl and [ __ ] like that alright I got
to see what it's like to to be in front
of somebody who knows how to throw at
you cuz it's a different situation game
it it's just like sometimes like a hit
I'm like how'd you do that how the [ __ ]
did you do that and even worse than that
I think the worst experience is not
necessarily getting hit the worst
experience is when you're tired oh man
okay that that's worse than anything
that moment when you know them little
people just crawl on your back and they
be holding you down and their lungs feel
like they bombs explode and you got to
go another round that's that's that's
one of those things where I started
respecting fighters more was when I
started sparring and exchanging and you
know we're like round four in and I
can't breathe right and then before that
I was like why do these fighters getting
so tired what you're supposed to do and
then like oh now I know why this is
[ __ ] hard artists like we're doing
two-minute rounds and round 2 by 2 round
2 is done I'm exhausted
ok I can't I can barely keep my [ __ ]
hands up man and and we you know when we
do our Saturday's we literally start at
11:30 a.m. and we probably go till
almost 1:00 and we do three-minute
rounds multiple I tell everybody in the
room if you need a break just take a
break but the bell just goes for three
minutes and we just continue going and
some guys will do ten or twelve rounds
straight before they take a break some
guys are do for you know me the og I'll
do one in one out yes I'm the one in one
out guy you know to read so you gonna
wanna
guy I got a good round it was nice
seeing you guys it was a I give somebody
work I'll sit down talk [ __ ] for around
and then I let them get tired and I go
in there and beat them up right after
you I think that's what I like when I
see like certain gyms like yours because
I you know when we watch the videos you
see people who are in your class that
you could tell they actually know how to
strike right whether they're there for
cardio kickboxing or whatever it doesn't
matter
no I don't matter some one way to teach
them there's only one way to teach
people yeah and and I've seen a lot of
other classes that I shadow too when I
first started it's like you've been
doing this for two years and you guys
still look like this yeah not a place
that I want to be at yes that's why I
like gyms like like sí sí yeah sí sí
like I didn't realize when I was
watching some of these videos and
footage of people like these people
aren't fighters they just look like five
years look like they got a good thing
going out there man shout out to Karen
that's the homie dude like he's a good
dude you know he built an environment of
winners you know and when you do that
you know everybody gets on board you
know what I mean everybody's on board
you get a couple good guys up there I
think it really kind of started up there
with Kevin Ross for them hmm
you know and then you know Eddie's their
young man I love it Eddie it's funny
because I kind of linked up to him
through Instagram but I've been watching
kickbox for quite a while yeah and I
just always loved his style so writing
style it's amazing like oh there's not
more tires you know it's his style yeah
you have your own you have your own
thing and that's and that's you develop
that by sparring you develop that by
getting all those rounds with all these
different people so that way you kind of
know how to mention it's like a mash-up
of everything that you learn from
whoever you you know experience in in
your training so yeah maybe they they
got a good thing up there man I really I
respect what they do I mean on the
CrossFit in and on the fighting in there
I think his gym is very knowledgeable
about their [ __ ] and they don't [ __ ]
around so you know it's like if you're
here just to I don't know just for like
cardio kickboxing that's cool but we're
gonna make sure that you look good too
and they know what you're doing there's
like teams like like team Aoyama and
Irvine - they got some killers that's
they got some killers yeah they've been
around a long time yeah you know like
I've known oh yeah my [ __ ]
from their team and you know guys like
Aoyama
respects guys like me because he knows
what i come from.he like watching me
come up you know every time I see him
it's like man savant I remember you beat
our guy you know we feel talking about
more stories and [ __ ] you know and I
think that's so cool they're like when
you could look back and there's no
animosity about because just like the
sport yes business yes like this what
was I not supposed to not knock you out
like we had a fight because you were
gonna do it to me or email either or so
that's the beauty of martial arts man we
get a chance to showcase it on a level
and you know even though it's fighting
you know we agreed to it and you know at
the end of the day one of us is gonna
win one's gonna go home so you know I
love it you know and and I have every
now and then I have just like little
shimmers of wanting to do it you know
what I mean you heard me talking about
it the other day yeah when you said that
you're gonna have another fight I was
like let's go I'll promote the [ __ ] out
of ya it's you know my wife was looking
at me like look the hell wrong what'd
you do post got deleted immediately
immediately immediately it's like take
that [ __ ] down here so there's like
still a part of you that feels it though
right well I mean and only because and
I'll tell you why it's not it's not that
I wanna like go and make any money or
you just want it's the thing that makes
me right you know fighting is what made
me what I am and I think it's the the
the process of it I'm attracted to you
know you want to have this goal of
alright I'm gonna be fighting on this
day so that means first of all gotta get
in shape you know it's like guaranteed
I'm gonna be in shape man I got a fight
you don't have no fight I'm like
whatever gives you a golden alert give
me something to work towards it give you
like a get up and go do it every day
thing and and then you want a rally at
you got people that rally behind you you
know I think that's always a good feel I
do get that last fight I had in Bellator
I mean I had a ton of people that came
to watch the fight and it just felt good
to have that support leading up to the
fight and it validated the gym and
people were talking about it you know so
that part you meant
I mean it's a good transition in a good
movement I think like the biggest
difference between you and a lot of
other fighters was you really did think
about an after that the the fighting
thing wasn't just gonna be your whole
life in the sense of I'm just gonna be
fighting reading till I die
yeah you know like you took your life
experiences all the knowledge that you
had you know what I'm trying to be Chuck
talk about that Chuck Liddell fight I
don't know who the [ __ ] was in that ring
that [ __ ] broke my heart man broke my
heart
to like it was like he was punching
through water I was like yo it was not
cool yo you know he was he was talking
about I could take John Jones before
that fight I'm like absolutely what is
going on Iceman and I mean and I'm and
I'm not gonna toot my own but I still
feel pretty formidable I feel like it
with the right match I could do well you
know but as a fighter you don't want
that to be the thing the way you get in
well with the right match like I want to
still have the like put me in there with
anybody I don't know
Uriah Faber came back and then you know
he came back with a huge overhand right
yeah crack them kale great move and then
he fought Peter Jani was all right these
kids built different these kids are
built different and I wasn't not trying
to be on the Indigo when they fed a
Peter Peter yeah I was like yeah that's
a little too soon man he ate his ass up
like like why would you even do that one
he was he was looking decently liaison
and then when I saw that one oh yeah
without the same night Kevin Lee fart
that was a crazy night oh my god yeah
man but you're our favorite you know
he's one of he was wondering I want this
man but what else does he have to prove
yeah exactly when he came back that was
the first thing that popped in my head I
was like you have nothing to prove no
like what what else do you need why even
come back he was like I want to see if I
can do I know we know you can do it yeah
you don't need to say it no leave it
alone
yeah and you know this guy Peter Yan is
built like a tank
I'm good these guys these kids now I'm
good yeah yeah well I mean what's what's
the next move for you uh you think about
expanding the gym or I mean I thought
about it um that might be something I
visit I think we've talked about it the
thing is I couldn't be you know I can't
be two places at one time yeah
I think if if some of the boys at the
gym really wanted to dedicate it to
another gym I'd be like hey let's open
another gym and kind of let them be the
ones that run it and take it on and it'd
be their thing and I'll just kind of
like shadow in the back and do certain
parts of it but it's a big undertaking
man and like there's so much you know
everybody's trying to do this online
training and all that which I never got
you know I never got the you're gonna
learn how to kickbox through a video
like I think the kickboxing aspect is
hard I think online training works well
with like strength and conditioning
maybe that just that you know nutrition
strength condition you can do it but for
fighting you really need somebody that
can explain all those little intricate
things to you so I mean I couldn't do
that it's a good way to get started for
people I think like for example they
have like the warrior collective they
have yeah yeah yeah I didn't feel for
the warrior collective from seeing what
they have it's not for people who just
want to start it's like you already
started you already know what you're
doing yeah I just want to kind of go
pick pick material that you can just say
I could do good from that cuz I can go
on there like I like I love Damien
Trainor
right yes so I'll go look at his stuff
like man that was lit let me let me try
maybe a trainer stuff I love it it's
just so hard to do he's alright it's
what we're gonna do with it hit a double
right hook yeah yeah the body high kick
low K yeah I'm like hold on I'm waiting
cozy I was you know he's kind of like
blend of Thai and Dutch style yeah so
he's crisp I I gravitate towards a stuff
right away you know so I don't know man
like for me as far as like moving
forward another gym would be cool but
you know I'm thinking like I want to
venture out and maybe start some other
type of business you know that's not gym
related whatever that may be you know
being that fighting is the only thing I
really do you know besides [ __ ]
around with cars or whatnot
but I'm having fun with it man I want to
be able to do martial art like martial
arts is something that I want to be able
to do till I absolutely can't and and
it's okay to do that right it's okay to
say hey man I lived off martial arts
until which a lot of people can't say
that a lot of people can't
after they fight they don't think about
their after and they're you know they're
trying to do like these that's that's
the crazy thing too is just because you
can find us it also doesn't mean that
you're a good businessman or a great
teacher no absolutely not
yeah yeah so you know I'm still in it
man I'm you know I'm gonna start doing
my nonprofit work I think that's gonna
be my real calling it's time to get more
into the nonprofit sector with the kids
you know hopefully I can I got a couple
athletes and I'm really working with
right now I got a girl who's a pretty
decent boxer that I've been training
that wants to like you know fight on an
Olympic level so you know who knows
maybe we can you know get I can beam in
somebody's corner carrying a bucket you
know on a higher-level boxing match at
some point so but it's fun man I've been
a I meet people through it you know
martial arts brings uh I think it brings
everybody together you know what I mean
it crosses all barriers and race and
everything you know when you're on the
mat you're on the mat you know and
nobody cares about where you're from and
what you do and where you say it's a
very honest like sport and hobby and
that's what I appreciate about ya
martial arts it's that's why I said like
the moment that you hit that mat you
could talk as much as you want
you're right when you exchange people
who see what you're about that's it
and that that that purity and honesty is
what I really really enjoyed and just
like watching people I think like I've
seen a lot of people change their lives
through martial arts absolutely like
they were troublemakers before but it's
a humbling thing too because you thought
you were big guy in the block you come
to a gym you get you ask me it's like yo
there's bigger peoples as well yeah
that's kind of how it was for me man it
actually saved you know I could have
been in trouble and all that but I was
like you know this is cool I got into it
and it became something that I just
never let go of and I think I'll be
doing this like we got some people in
the gym that are older that do this and
they never were fighters but they're in
the gym training people to on the I see
the same dudes I'm like yeah this is
that was it exactly and they love it you
know and like some of my kids that uh
started really young that left to go do
wrestling you know some of them are in
college wrestling now
you know we got new a new crop of kids
that are you know not good but they'll
be good and we just had like a new wave
of kids you know we had our first decade
and out of that decade you know we got
some kids in college we got we see them
now I got all these new ones and I'm
like man we got to do this all over
again
that's things you like these kids have
to know you know people get disappointed
when they first start but it's like
everybody has to start from somewhere
you gotta start somewhere
you guys see the videos when I first
done every day one yeah it was hard to
watch it it was it was pretty tough bro
let me tell you this know when I in my
mind though I was like yo my shit's
tight yeah you know but then you look at
the video I'm like you know who put this
on slow-mo yeah why hit so slice it hits
you with the little gym like hey man
keep your hand up
I still have someone with that [ __ ]
[ __ ] tech one no habit [ __ ] when I
get tired of my [ __ ] right hand
starts to drop lower as well [ __ ] it
got a funny way of showing you manage it
you know Nick Nick's funny cuz Nick
sometimes has that that little fight dog
in him still yeah so like he he will
choose not to spar most of the time but
one day he'll be like I got gloves on
I'm like yeah and I was done he just
starts pieces yeah be money up I'm like
damn man like it's funny because when I
see him like I feel like he could still
fight but he just doesn't want it you
don't want it yeah yeah okay Nick always
that game though he's had some swag that
little crop of guys that that came up
with us
they all had game like and I think
they're all worthy like coaches and you
know they've shown the real because
there's a lot of phonies man I swear
there's so many of them out there and
I'm like and I'd be inviting them me I'm
kind of you know crazy like that man you
should come on in man and get some
rounds come get this work and they never
show up of course they don't want they
don't want that he know that's gonna be
really like for me I'll be trying to put
my little dudes on him like Nico you
know to me he goes a monster that'll
suck me in the face
[ __ ] empty no kid just [ __ ] give
it a [ __ ] combat you know [ __ ] I
don't even spar well no more
I saw like he just put up a clip on his
story of him just exchanging oh my god
and that dude was a pro that Larissa one
Oh was that I was like Nick oh my god
like he did this real quick he was like
backed up to the wall yes he threw a
couple of Hicks pushed him off to the
side crack that cross I was like clean
yeah he's a killer yeah we're gonna get
him to fight something he needs it oh
man I am he's been doing it for such a
hurry was training at said y'all talk to
us it's just before he came with us he
was at see it song as a kid he's
probably being with me for maybe six I
think now about six years solid well you
know and he's tough man like Nico is a
tough kid this is all he really knows
how to do he loves it you know he's just
a good kid that's that's the thing about
practitioners if you have a good
spirited good-hearted person that does
martial arts they come out good because
they just have it in him this kid was
like he was I hate David like I want to
come out and train with you it's like
yeah if you sock me like less he has one
mode in that one with a smile on his
face did I hit you to look at my nose
yes but I like it though because he got
that fire when I see him I'm like that
that's what a fighter's made out yeah
but you need that heat yeah he doesn't
look the part right you know I always
tell people a they like I had guys come
to me like a man a one kid man asian kid
he's [ __ ] tough man like yeah he's
he's [ __ ] hands are so clean clean it's
[ __ ] hard to I'm like yeah you so
hard you look so gentle yes he's a
gentle giant it looks like he makes
loopy us for living in this one he's
[ __ ] people up and [ __ ] did hilarious
but you gotta come by man we we we gotta
you gotta come in yeah I'm trying to get
earn your real strike I gotta kill this
foot cuz I got my [ __ ] [ __ ] an
e-check by a cat check my Kenzo power
okay I just uh I threw a really stupid
just floppy front kick and I got the top
of your foot he got the bottom of my
foot Wow I never had that happen before
but that was my fault because I think
like sometimes when I'm sparring people
who are smaller I always tend to pull
back a little bit but I can't pull back
on somebody like him because he's was
first of all he could take the hit so it
doesn't matter right and then if I pull
it back on him I'm not gonna connect so
it's just like he told me recently he
goes do you just just throw it I'm not
gonna get hurt okay well thank you
because before because the sock is that
I'm also scared if I hit him hard he's
like you're gonna [ __ ] he's always good
at controlling it though cuz he need
some hammer that lightweight I'm just
gonna tell him to meet me up and it's
gonna be you yeah exactly
enjoy I'll meet you on Saturday well
yeah well thanks for coming through what
can they find you obviously first of all
if you guys want to train some MMA and
you want to do with some really legit
just place that I first started out and
was probably one of the the bigger
blessings in my life because when I
first came up there I was like 270
pounds and yeah man it was just a
witness
you know either witness you know and I
didn't know how to throw a single
[ __ ] punch and it was it was it was
something new and I think the
environments great and if you guys want
to actually learn how to fight and if
you don't want to fight just come
through the fight academy Pasadena man
yeah we out here man 10 years you can
Google us Google me fight Academy
Pasadena com
we out here man you gonna find us if you
look up any MMA in Pasadena
you're gonna find us for sure yeah man I
think I think the great thing about the
gym too is like it's it's if you want to
be a fighter you could be a fighter if
not if you just better train and learn
about the sport it's also there for you
there man away it's no egos man we just
we just there to work and I think you
know no fighter makes it to the ring by
themselves you know what I mean there's
a team behind them you know there's the
the casuals I call them those are the
guys that are buying your t-shirts and
your tickets and you know I mean so it's
a real big network that you have in the
gym environment and we've been real
fortunate to like survive for 10 years
man
[ __ ] ain't easy to do and business for
ten years is amazing a period you know
let alone a fight Jim yeah because
people don't like to pay for training I
will say that Brig Brig I you know I'm
taking a couple of boxing lessons from
this guy PJ and PJ's pretty good I've
seen it
PJ PJ cleans man he's clean he's pretty
good I like his stuff I think the
important thing that he always said too
is like you know prices aren't really
based on what you can afford is what I
can offer you all right so it's like
it's based on my skillset and what I can
offer ya like I can't because you can't
afford it it doesn't mean that my
skillset dumbs down right which is what
I really do appreciate like you really
do get what you pay for in anything in
life well in the real somebody's
charging you like 25 bucks for boxing
lenses just just to let you know you get
in $25.00 what you're gonna get 100%
there's not a single person doing
personal training out there and this is
from personal experience if if you get
if somebody's charging 25 bucks 50 bucks
for boxing lessons I [ __ ] guarantee
you it's not gonna be good it's just not
depending on where you from specifically
in LA yeah I I by the way this is from
personal experience so I've gone to the
guy who charged 25 bucks 50 bucks right
and it was a terrible terrible
experience I didn't know what they were
doing and I wasn't learning anything so
you know get what you pay for and it was
something that you enjoy
then then really pay for it like it does
work out yeah or with that yeah thanks
so Instagram I believe in a bar up for
us because it's a lot of trash okay I
just I just I want to set that bar for
people in general when it comes to this
stuff because don't don't [ __ ] waste
your money yeah don't waste your time
don't waste your money cuz all that like
time is limited so if you can come to a
gym and you could spend good money let's
say just for like three four months like
you're spending a good amount of money
well in that three or four months is
more than you'll gain in that year that
you'll get with absolutely with that
$25.00 absolutely no personal experience
just kind of putting out that you could
take that advice to leave it but trust
me I'll put up a video of how I used to
look before it's a different it's a
different experience yeah you parted a
bloodline yeah
like when I first I don't know what I
did a first low kick on that bag I
almost cried there you did that's it
that [ __ ] [ __ ] hurt I'm like the [ __ ]
that's so funny it was like it'll feel
better I'm like man it does feel better
than laughing well yeah man thank you no
I appreciate you having me here man
nah man like I I definitely wanted I
think like sometimes when I talk about a
lot of the the fight stuff I I
definitely want somebody credible to
speak about their experience because
there are people that message me that
want to get into fighting I want to know
what it's like and you know there's a
reason why ninety-eight percent of
people don't make it in there but it
doesn't mean that you shouldn't try and
you shouldn't you know give it a go
because I'm never gonna fight but I do
appreciate if nothing wrong with knowing
it and I tell people that all the time
don't come in with that expectation just
come in and just accept it do it and
just get better that's the name of the
game just get better yeah you know and
you're not gonna get better with you
know 30 minutes twice a week you know
you know you got to put some time in
like you got to do it anything else and
just take the good with the bad
push it I used to train with Nick and
then on the off days I went to a tennis
court and I just used the lines to work
on for senior working man yeah yeah you
were doing it yeah that's why I would
chime in come out we'll see you trying
to get it you know I don't want to waste
anybody's time you know it's like I'm
paying for this [ __ ] like I'm gonna make
sure that I make sure you got it exactly
yeah well you can find well can they
find you first of all just kind of put
that out uh WWF I'd Academy Pasadena
calm my handle is just sivan young on
Instagram Facebook and that's pretty
much it man yeah well follow savant and
then fall fight Academy Pasadena come in
to fight Academy to get that work it's
every Saturday every Saturday you'll see
me there laughing through the window and
see what's up daddy cover guys I'm not
to be in the I get scared on the
beginner area too sometimes because
that's where they kind of just throw
hard they don't know what's up so I
might have to be like in the middle just
I'm gonna but I love to start tagging
you and [ __ ] you coming I appreciate
well you guys would catch the genius
brain podcast on all audio platforms
leave in the comments below about what
you think and then we'll see y'all next
time
boo yeah please Cheers